Wade Shelton is sticking up for his new  The Voice co-star Miley Cyrus thank you  very much here's what Blake had to say  about the wrecking ball singer on the  latest episode of a Chelsea  I think Miley's just one of the most  talented people I mean that girl can  really sing I feel like her antics  sometimes keep people from realizing  just focusing on what an incredible yes  singer she is when she just seems like I  don't realize until those moments it's  like oh my god she's at different genres  she can do different things we know this  like a commercial for Miley Cyrus good  luck  Miley joins the voice as a coach this  fall I know we're so excited